so after you achieve success a lot of
Tempe's people stopped working that hard
they come in at 11 o'clock instead of 7
o'clock in the morning and do cardio
they stop taking care their diet they
kind of start eating out too much they
put on 30 40 50 pounds they work less
they're no longer coming to work working
very hard so what happens when you the
leader doesn't work very hard
psychologically you don't expect as much
effort from everybody because you're not
putting everything in and this leads me
to number 3 when you don't give
everything to everybody in your brain
you become very paranoid thinking this
person is about to leave you that person
is about to quit this person is about to
take off this person is going to go to a
competitor so rather than leading your
organization which is what people want
they want to be led you become someone
that is solving for being liked by
everybody so you become a people pleaser
and there isn't any leader I know that's
building an organization on high
standards that maintains it while
wanting to please everybody in the
organization those two just don't go
together